So you would know like who's going to
win beforehand because it's going to be
the demons that control the game
>> really.
>> Yeah. Or you already know who's going to
win. Like if you know how you have all
these big um a super athletes. Yes.
People are talented but a lot of them
it's not them that's doing it and it's
not them that's winning it. It's all um
predetermined. And a lot of them who are
the big super athletes and so on, they
know that it's not them.
>> So you're saying a lot of these athletes
know it's not them. We talk a lot about
celebrities specifically in the music
industry, in the movie industry, actors.
Yeah. They give hints sometimes. They
openly say it that they worship the the
prince of this world. I believe it's
even uh Bob Dylan who even said like
>> crossroads deal.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Yeah.
>> Do you still do it? Why are you still
out here?
>> Well, it goes back to the destiny thing
and I made a bargain with it, you know,
a long time ago and I'm holding up my
hand.
>> What was your bargain?
>> To get where uh I am now.
>> Should I ask who you made the bargain
with
>> with with with, you know, with the chief
uh chief commander
>> on this earth?
>> On this earth and in a world we can't
see. But I've never really heard it say
about athletes. So, but but are you
saying that since a lot of them know
it's not them doing it? Are they some of
them dabbling with these kind of things?
Like they're dabbling with
>> Yeah. Oh, they they have to be some of
them to be at the level that they are,
>> right? Are you familiar with Tom Brady's
former wife? So, they've been divorced
for a couple years now, but when he
first went to Tampa Bay, he's like
getting his hair done. and he's telling
the story to these reporters and he's
basically saying that his wife is a
witch, but she's a good witch.
>> Any superstitions going into the game?
Any special thing you carried into the
game on Sunday that you had tucked away
somewhere?
>> Uh, I did. I always um, you know, I've
learned a lot from my wife over the
years. She's so about the power of
intention, you know, and believing
things that are really going to happen.
and she always makes a little altar for
me at the game because she she just
wills it so much. And uh so she put
together a little altar for me that I
could bring with pictures of my kids and
I have these little special stones and
healing stones and protection stones and
she has me wear necklace and take these
drops she makes. I say all these mantras
and I stopped questioning her a long
time ago. I did. I just shut up and
listen. And at first I was like, "This
is kind of crazy." And then about 4
years ago, we were playing the Seahawks
and she said, "You better listen to me.
This is your year, but this is all the
things you're going to have to do to
win." And I did all those things. And by
God, you don't worked. It was pretty
good.
>> And then in 2015, it was about early
January, and she said, "You know how
much I love you." And I said, "Yeah."
And she said, "I just want to let you
know this is not going to be your year."
>> And of course, we lost. I said, "What
does 16 look like?"
and she said 16's going to be your year.
So it was early January this year and I
said babe I asking like do we have a
chance and she said yeah but you're
going to have to do a lot of work and
you're really going to have to listen to
me.
So man I listened to her and right after
the game she said see I did a lot of
work. You do your work I do mine.
She said you're lucky you married a
witch. I'm just a good witch. It sounds
like you're familiar with that as well.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I heard it and I thought,
"Yep, sounds right." My dad before he
died, my my dad was into I I would say
voodoo. I want to say witchcraft, but I
feel like voodoo is a little um
stronger. I would say he was kind of
like high up like he was higher than
most of the other people that practiced
it.
>> Okay.
>> So, yeah. So he would have politicians
and sports people and people that were
not even from that country would come
over there to to see him. But like
voodoo is like really deep oult. So like
yeah you'll you'll be sitting there
talking face to face with Satan kind of
thing. Oh, a lot of people who did oult
and did kudu, um, they would say, "Okay,
you have to go buy this animal and bring
it back and we'll do such and such and
such." He didn't do any of that because
he worked directly with with demons face
to face. Like he when he was 17, he went
into the forest and he was there for
like I want to say 30 days, 30, 40 days,
something like that. he was there where
the demons were face to face talking to
him and training him and and when he
came back out of the forest is when he
began this work. So he was kind of a
notch above the others which is why
people came to him. Well, it's
interesting that Travis Kelsey, we've
done a video on our channel about Taylor
Swift and kind of went deep into it and
she's hugely involved in the occult and
and like um magic and witchcraft and and
and all these kind of things. And so,
yeah, you would assume if you're as an
athlete dating someone like that, you
must know something. You must know,
right?
>> And you know, their team, I'm not making
uh making statements here that about why
their team won. And I don't know what
transpired behind the scenes about that,
but their team fit in.
>> They did. Yep. Yep. First year they were
dating.
>> So, is there any kind of specific uh uh
leadup to some of these big events that
are, you know, basically dedicated to
Satan? Was there any discussion about
that
>> like the Super Bowl and stuff,
>> right?
>> Mhm. If you were into sports and you
had, you know, a big things coming up
where you can win a tournament, you win
a you win money, you win a league, you
would come to him and he would say,
"Okay." And then, you know, you would
win every game. You win and then you
move up and then finals and everything
and then you're the winner.
>> Like the Super Bowl, right? Like you
mentioned Yeah.
>> Yeah.